first of all congratulations on your
sophomore album you know what's really
cool you're you're in your 30s you're a
dad where is your head at and your heart
at when it was coming to creating this
album in this new music
there was there was two kind of Concepts
or two kind of topics that I kept coming
back to with writing this record and it
was um it was choices and and and
changes and I think that's that's kind
of relevant to my age and and definitely
there's a lot of what changes kind of
going on around me there's a lot of
choices that I've had to make in my
career so I think you know this this
album it does carry a slightly different
I don't even it makes me cringe saying
this bit like a slightly different
maturity to the lyric I don't think I
would have been able to write this album
like five years ago
um I do think there's slightly more
perspective there maybe
okay so why does the word maturity make
you cringe a little
sounds like I don't know just sound like
a [ __ ] know it all Donna
hey if you've learned a lot since your
20s then that's good there you go yeah
exactly I love that so much um you know
I I know you had your hand uh in this
album more than any other albums you've
worked on with One Direction or even
your your first solo album what
experience was that like having so much
control on this
it wasn't it wasn't the fact that I
didn't you know have control on the
first record it's just that I wasn't
brave enough on my first album in
general really
um and I'm really proud of all the songs
that that I made on that recording it
and it made a great tour and great
experience for me but at the same time
this record is it's just a better advert
for me as an artist the kind of stuff
like that I like listening to
um conceptually I don't think it's kind
of changed load since the first record
it's more more about the sound and the
feel and and all I wanted out of this
record was for it to feel hopeful but
also something that's going to work and
shine in in at the live shows
when you say hopeful I feel like that
really is a great word to describe the
album faith in the future was that done
on purpose to have this optimistic
outlook on on these songs definitely I
think you know I think that that is who
I am as a person I'm not lucky enough to
have always kind of been like that but
also there was a certain weight to my
first album emotionally and I wanted to
kind of Escape that I wanted to move
away from that because again that's not
really who I am as a person so I wanted
something straight away from the title
from the off to feel optimistic and
hopeful and I think that that that
sentiment that statement definitely does
that do you consider yourself a
perfectionist when it comes to work
do you know what I I I I would say no
but I think I think all artists are I
think it's sometimes you know especially
within songwriting it's about just
because you can be over analytical
forever you know and you can you can you
can read into lyrics and different
sounds that you've used over and over
and over again at some point you kind of
just have to let it go but I think it's
kind of natural in the job that I do to
be a perfectionist yeah you know when
you have a song like bigger than me and
and you choose that as like the the lead
song on the on this album what was
special about this song
I don't think I have another song like
it on the record it's it's got It's got
that it's got a certain level of scale
to it it's got that big soaring chorus
and I think you know because of that it
kind of feels like an ambitious first
look on this first record on this second
record and what I wanted was for you to
feel the growth from the first record to
this record now and I think that song
kind of does that gives me an
opportunity to kind of showcase my vocal
shows what I've been doing as a
songwriter etc etc and the video is
fantastic is this was this the video
that was shot in Iceland yeah amazing
proper beautiful place
what was that experience like yeah
amazing um I've been lucky enough to be
there I was there a couple of months
before on tour which was also a great
experience
um but to be there for the video
um yeah it was beautiful I mean again
what we wanted we wanted to kind of
match that chorus and to have a certain
level of scale in terms of the visual
and that's the thing about Iceland it's
so vast and so beautiful
um it definitely definitely did that for
us
amazing so when it comes to your fans
listening to this album what is it that
you want them to take away from it
um
I want I want them to listen to the
record and be excited about the next
tour because that the whole record was
written with the live show in mind yeah
that's smart and creating those you know
exciting live moments because me as a as
a music fan they're the moments that you
know stay in my mind they're the
memories
um so hopefully listen to the record and
just being excited about what's the
common and the next tour and stuff like
that what does life on tour look like
for you now
um
it's not the real world it's it's it's
it's it's pretty great
um depends depends I mean an average day
I'd probably be waking up far too late
because that's just the lifestyle
um there's a lot of waiting around on
tour before you kind of get around to
doing what you do but you know there's
so much travel and you see so many
different places and although you're not
in each place for that long
it's just a really exciting time and I'm
lucky enough to have a great
relationship with my band and stuff like
that so yeah
um pretty much every day is a load of
fun yeah I know that your son recently
got to see perform for the first time
what was that like for you oh it was it
was dead emotional it was really really
nice uh really nice yeah first time he's
been to see me like that um and for
maybe the first four or five songs I was
trying to find him in the crowd but I
couldn't spot them and then I finally
found out where he was and as soon as I
saw him I was well enough it was uh it
was lovely it was lovely he came with
his own little Banner like oh did you
expect to have those kind of emotions
um listen I knew I was going to be
emotional I didn't realize just how much
it was going to kind of choke me up in
the moment
but it was lovely it was lovely it was
funny it brought its own kind of
pressure I really wanted to deliver that
night knowing he was watching I love
that
um do you you know with you being a dad
and you know you're on tour and you're
this musician do you try to draw that
line between you know Louie is the the
artist Louie's the dad very much so yeah
I think it's I think that's important
you know both for our relationship but
also like for my own sanity you know
like I live in I'm very aware that I
don't live in the real world when
especially when I'm on tour or you know
when I'm doing you know my performances
Etc but when I when I you know when I
spend my time with Freddie I do feel
like I put my dad hat on and there's a
slightly different version of myself
that I have to be obviously like like
all parents yeah what kind of a dad are
you
um do you know what I'm pretty I'm
actually pretty strict listening oh yeah
I I I'm I'm pretty strict but only on
like like Essentials like for example
like manners like please and thank yous
like I'll correct him every single time
if he misses that
um but I'd say I'm a pretty good and I'm
pretty fun but I'm pretty sure when I
need to be I feel like that's a good
balance you know I feel like that's good
um how exciting is a time like this for
you in your life yeah really exciting I
feel like I've been my whole solo career
I've kind of been working up to this
part really and working up to this kind
of feeling because now I've got a full
tour under my belt and I'm really really
confident about the music that I'm
making I think it you know it kind of
honors me as as an artist so I feel
really good you know it's a really good
time for me and I'm excited about what
what comes next yeah do you hear from
your fellow One Direction fans and and
and band members you know when you are
putting up new music like like this do
you feel the support from everyone yeah
it's probably more likely to come on the
album yeah because you know what it's
like these days there's there's so many
different singles we'll be texting each
of every every other week well normally
around the album like that's when I
normally make sure to try and take the
lads and I'm sure they'll do the same
um but um yeah cookware last did text me
actually over the single now comes think
of it they did yeah I love that that
must feel good just still always having
that that friendship and that support
yeah we're we're we're brothers we
experience so much together so we're I
think it's important we do that future
but yeah I have to tell you this was so
much fun getting to talk to you
congratulations on everything going on
your life right now and uh good luck
with the tour thank you very much thanks
a lot